wait up wait up ooh
who doesn't love Winnie the Pooh hell
he's like one of the most innocent
things on the planet I think there's a
law actually forbidding people not to
like it
I know people who despise Mickey Mouse
but they can't bring themselves to
actually say they hate Winnie the Pooh
so what is it what is it that just makes
him so likable well I think a lot of it
has to deal with the fact that while he
is very optimistic he does make mistakes
and he does get in trouble
he's very naive but he's also very
pleasant and I think that makes him much
more interesting than someone like
Mickey Mouse he's still positive but
there's just much more of a character to
play with and it all started with this
one film The Many Adventures of Winnie
the Pooh these characters are so famous
now I don't even have to name them
kangaroo Tigger owl rabbit piglet Yee or
the list goes on the story is very loose
in that there's not that much of a
flowing narrative it's just sort of the
life of Pooh and his friends through the
course of Mao No
a year maybe it's just all the troubles
circumstances and weird situations they
get in and how they manage to live or
get around it as a kid I liked it fine
but watching it now years later actually
it's a lot better than I remember it
they actually make a lot of fourth-wall
jokes using the book that they're in and
even sometimes talk with the narrator so
we come to the next chapter in which but
I haven't finished yet oh you're in
chapter Oh what happened to me well
let's turn the page and find out but
that's not the only reason it's good
there's just this sense to it this
atmosphere this real like ability to
this world that they've created it's
very laid back it's very slow pace but
at the same time these characters are
just so interesting and so nice that you
really enjoy spending time with them you
don't care if not much is going on you
could just have a conversation with any
one of these people and you probably be
very satisfied I really like movies like
that they don't feel they have to stick
to the three-act structure and instead
just let you shoot the for a bit
they just like characters breathe and do
whatever it is they do and these
characters are really enjoyable and the
situation's they get in are really
enjoyable we got some real creative
scenarios with a windstorm who trying to
get more honey and of course another
trip is held Disney scene with epilim
sand Woozles
animals only is very unusual moves every
slimy slide yeah the songs are catchy
and clever the animation I think
actually matches the mood and style are
going for and like I said there's just a
real heavy atmosphere to it don't you
like the ending there's no big climax no
chasey no major discoveries it's just
Christopher Robin talking with his
imaginary friend any inevitability of
the future who when I'm away just doing
nothing will you come up here sometimes
you mean alone just me yes come Pooh
promise you won't forget me ever oh I
won't Christopher I promise that's
actually kind of heavy stuff honey the
Pooh is not often looked at as one of
the great Disney films but it is look at
as one of the great Disney characters
and that's all the film is just enjoying
this character and all the people that's
around him it's clever it's nice it's
friendly I really enjoyed watching it
again in fact it's one of the few Disney
films where I like it just as much as a
kid as I do as an adult it takes me
right back to that same place I enjoy
and I always love coming back
you